Our experts in emotion interview
will be with our Touro.
They Har the director of engineering at
Facebook and he'll be speaking with us
on emotion and social media.
Arturo as director of
engineering at Facebook,
has worked on social tools to help
people be more mindful of each other.
This includes such areas as
identity and abuse prevention,
ways to develop better online citizens
and tools designed to help resolve
conflicts between
individuals such as bullying.
Previously he worked at Yahoo where he
worked with a global team dedicated to
providing a secure online experience.
So I now turn to our last experts and
emotion interview together with our tour
obey Har on emotion and social media.
So welcome Arturo.
Thank you for speaking with us today.
Thank you very much for hosting me.
Great.
So I wanted to start just by asking you
a little bit about what first got you
interested in studying emotion
in the context of Facebook,
in the broader world of social media.
So we're looking at the reports that we're
getting from people about photographs
that they have upload on Facebook.
And usually it's most sites too.
You have these reports that are
about the rules of the site.
This has some violence, discuss some
drug use. And somebody says, Hey,
this photo has Greg Hughes,
can you please make it go away?
And we would look at the phone and
there was nothing in the photo,
even remotely looked like that.
It was just somebody like smiling,
waving at the camera and like,
what's going on here?
And we realized that the person
that we're submitting the report,
in many cases,
most cases was in the photo and
the person had uploaded the photo,
was one of their friends. Um, and so
we're like, how can we help with this?
And we figured out, okay, so you want
people to be talking to each other.
So we told them, hey, can you
send a message to your friends,
letting them know that you would
like them to remove the picture?
And we put on an empty message box
and only 20% of people would send the
message. And, um, and then in most cases,
even the messages didn't convey really
what, what it's like, hey, you know,
this photo,
there's something about it that makes
me want to ask you to take it down.
At that time, we began meeting people, um,
that are doing research scientist
from Stanford and Berkeley. And yeah,
we're doing all of this research about
how people communicate and relate to each
other.
And one of the things that we learned
is if you pick up that somebody else is
experiencing an emotion, you're more
likely to have a compassionate response.
You're more likely to want to help them.
So we did this experiment
where we provided some
default messaging that people
can edit and send saying, hey,
you know, I don't like this photo.
Could you please to gate down.
It makes me sad,
but experimented with emotion and we saw
a really meaningful results from that.
Over 50% of people would send a message
and then most of the people who receive
the message would remove
the photo. Um, I mean,
we knew we were onto something
and this was where it began.
A lawyers of collaborations
we're doing right now.
We're exploring what are ways that people
can communicate emotion to each other
online.
That's fascinating. And so I
wanted to ask you then, you know,
the work that you're doing right now
at Facebook related to emotion. Um,
what role have you found
in this work so far?
I'm suggesting that emotion does play
a role in these online interactions and
Facebook.
Okay.
Oh, it is a central, um, uh, because it's,
it's central to be how people
relate with each other. Um, we're,
we have this flow now that that'd
be put into place where we say, Hey,
I'm in the photo. I don't want
others to see me in the story.
If you're known as a framing on
that is, it's very emotional. Um,
and then we asked you what is it about
this photo that you don't like and we'll
give you options that our emotions, it's
embarrassing. It's about photo of me,
not as much emotion, but an
important thing to convey.
It makes me angry or upset.
It makes me sad.
Um,
and we found that people would
select an emotion and then,
um,
uh,
take the message where we provided that
incorporated what we have learned about
politeness and how you
communicate. So, um, Hey Alan,
is there something about this photo
that's a little embarrassing to me? Um,
could you please take it down?
And we found that over 60,
I think 67% of the people will actually
send the message, which is huge.
Wow. Um, and, uh,
depending on the message between 80 and
90% of people will use the texts that we
provided, um, which means that
we've captured their experience. Um,
and even,
um,
I think more exciting than that is
we asked the people who had created,
uploaded the photo, the content
creators, how they felt about the person,
what sent them the message.
Um,
and remember this is somebody who is
just share something with all of their
friends because they think
it's really cool. And one of
the friends told him, Hey,
you know, that actually, you
know, it's upsetting to me. Well,
it turns out that the person who receives
the message feels at 60% positive,
like 6% of them feel positive about the
person who sent them the message. Wow. Um,
and another 20%, they feel neutral.
So it's like 80% of people,
they kind of want to know if they did
something that was upsetting to you,
which is very interesting to contrast
against the only 20% of people willing to
communicate that emotion to their
friends to help resolve the situation.
It's so interesting.
So in what way do you think is
worth thinking about these emotional
relationships between people? You know,
I'm trying to do things that will foster,
you know, more positive
interactions online. Um,
I want to ask a little bit about your
work suggesting that Facebook may actually
be one route to sort of cultivate,
you know, compassion and encourage it.
Well,
we think based on the research that
we've seen about how if you detect that
somebody else is experiencing emotion,
you're more likely to want
to ease their suffering.
And so hence the engage in a kind
of question and response. Um,
so I think we all know that,
uh,
emails and messages might not be the best
way to convey. As at certain emotions,
happy emotions are actually fairly
easy to convey like smiley faces,
like buttons.
These things are very easy to convey
that our positive feelings but conveying
more complicated emotional
stake, something gets
embarrassing or something sad.
Uh, we have looked at all
of these mechanisms that we
have when we talk to each
other where we can, we
didn't, somebody faces,
you can hear it and
that's one of their boys.
And there's an absence of that
today in many online communications.
And so when we look at
the fabric of Facebook,
which is all about connecting people
to each other and having great
relationships and cultivating
that community over time, um,
having a mechanism that takes something
that could be a source of distancing. Um,
if, if you uploaded a photo and it made
me upset and I didn't tell you anything
about it, that that pushes
people further apart. Yeah. It,
instead of having that you could have
something where you can communicate how
you feel and you can feel hurt.
The other person says, Oh,
I'm sorry it made you feel this way too.
It's not my intent at all.
And you begin a dialogue,
even if the father doesn't come down,
which is a perfectly legitimate outcome,
that relationship gets closer
and that bonds Franklin's.
And so we hope if we have interactions
that have positive results for people,
that people will go like, and then what
happened there? What can I learn from,
from that communication and take this
into other aspects of their lives.
So when you think about trying to
promote a community that brings people
together as opposed to
distancing them apart,
is this part of the reason underlying,
you know,
why there might not be the dislike button
that a lot of people are often asking
about?
I think so. I mean, I think
that, um, uh, this like, uh,
could be very easily misinterpreted and
the ideal form of a dislike is one that
begins a conversation. Um, so you
want to be able to say, hey, you know,
that thing that you, ah, shit, I disagree
with that. Um, or that thing that,
um, that, that you posted and Maytag and
make me sad. It was upsetting to me. Um,
and you need really good ways of
communicating emotion for that to be a
successful conversation.
Um,
and so we're starting in this realm
of like photos and feedback. Um, and,
and uh,
and also bullying is another area that
we're exploring to build tools that can
successfully communicate
emotion to and between people,
these more complicated emotions. Um, but
we hope that if we do a good job on this,
that what we can learn here can be
applied in many other areas of online
communication.
So in embarking in this really,
you know,
still mysterious but rapidly growing
world, you know, of online interaction,
has there been anything
that's really surprised you
during your time at Facebook?
Oh, man. Every step along
the way, there's game.
So crisis, um, [inaudible] talks about,
which is only 20% of the people willing
to send a message telling their friends,
but most of their friends wanting to
hear about and feeling good about the
contact. That was a really big
surprise. Um, another one is, uh,
when people come into the report
flow for most of them over 80%,
it's extremely important, um,
for the photo to go to come down.
But we believe that the action of um,
acknowledging this is what's happening,
naming the emotion that
you're experiencing and then
communicating that to the
other person in a way where you feel
like you've successfully, um, eh, eh,
are heard.
Um,
the combination of those things make it
so that at the end of that experience we
asked them how they feel about the person
that uploaded the photo and the number
said or 50% positive. Um, which is again,
it's surprising considering you're
going into this going like, oh wait,
did you share this at the same metric?
Me,
another one that I think has
been a very important insight,
which goes against anything that you've
seen in terms of computer design.
And experience is that you get taught
in all computer design classes.
That language has to be very clear
and very universal. So we been there,
this,
this slide where we can ask for a motion
photo makes you feel our first version
of it had adjectives. I'm like
embarrassing. Just the word embarrassing.
I just the word saddening. And we just
had that the simplest, cleanest Ui.
And then we had an option to in other
where people could type in and only at 50%
of people would select
an emotion and then, uh,
the other people and other 30%
would put something in other.
And what would they select in other, it
would type in, it's embarrassing. Hmm.
We're going like, wait, there was like
an option for him. What's going on? Um,
well it turns out that it's important
when you design things online that you use
language that matches the experience.
Can they,
that people use when they talk
about things with each other.
So we change the options to sentence
fragments. It's embarrassing.
It makes, uh, um, and,
and when we changed the emotions
to a sentence fragments,
we went from a 50% selection to 78%,
which is in the world of online systems
that that 30 point swings are just like
completely nuts and wonderful.
Um,
and we've applied that principle in other
areas of the work where the language
is much longer and much more descriptive
than what you would expect from any
normal product that you have.
But all of the measures of the language
say having language that matches people
experience at captured,
whether it is that they're feeling that
they're trying to say steak really works
and, and, and to the tune of 20%,
30% improvements in the areas where
we've applied these principles.
Wow.
So in what way have you felt that your
collaborations with people at Berkeley
like Dacher Keltner, Paul Piff, you know,
people at Yale like Marc
Brackett among many others, um,
how has this work from people who
study aspect of science, you know,
in psychology.
How has that informed the kind of work
that you're doing now at Facebook?
Oh, it's been insanely wonderful. Good.
Well because, uh, it, it, it,
everything I'm talking about has been
born out of conversations with them.
So in the work we've been
doing with, with mark, um,
at bracket from Yale on bullying,
um,
we're asking these really
big questions about like,
what kind of bullying is happening
for you? How does it make you feel?
How intense is the emotion? I mean, it's,
this is, it's pretty big to say, hey,
are you feeling afraid
halfway? Do you feel, um, and,
but it's central for being able to get
people kind of the tools that they need
and the department,
and these are very close partnerships
where we meet up with them once a week and
we talked through the different ideas.
We share the numbers, um, and, and uh,
and the same has been proved
the relationship with Paul,
I piss and attackers and the,
I'm on Thomas from Berkeley where we sit
down and we'll look at the experiences
people are having and we're
asking the big question of like,
what's really going on here?
What punches?
And when we first began
getting exposed to the word,
like that emotional intelligence
work. And, and the, um,
as a self regulation and emotional
literacy for kids with mark, uh,
and bracket and the work that,
uh,
they were good is doing with Paul's
work and that work and Eliana sport,
but in some ways that people communicate
in motion with each other. Um, it was,
it was very exciting for us
because we're like, okay, this,
this is a total application for
everything we're doing. And,
and it was the basis of,
of the compassionate research stay that
we have or which we have another one
tomorrow.
They were very excited about.
That's so exciting to hear that Facebook
is taking the science of emotion and
using it to change the way that we
interact with this world of Facebook.
That's so many people participate in.
Yes. And it's, it's our hope by talking
about it like talking with you today,
but having a confessional research to
any sort of other outlets that we're
pursuing to help other people understand
just how much we've gotten out of our
partnerships with, uh, our
researcher friends. Um,
and, uh, and because I think anybody who's
building any kind of tools to enable to
medication or to be learning from what
we were learning out to be working with
their local scientists to figure out
how they can explore these ideas. Um,
because by every measure
of the work we've done,
it's been a positive thing for the
people who use Facebook. Um, and um,
and we hope that by the data that we get,
and then we sorta put sharings that
illuminates some pathways in the fields
because one of the things you talk
about when I'm getting started is most
studies in the field and what was 200
people and everything we've done here
spends hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people that have gone through
this. And they're telling us that's
making the feel and it's like the results.
Cause we help open up pathways for
other areas of research and inquiry.
I mean absolutely those, those kinds of
sample sizes or things that, you know,
psychologists like myself and
the ones you collaborate with,
we could never dream of.
Right. You know, you be there.
Yeah. Facebook, you know,
not so bad when it comes to just
being able to access so many people.
Right.
And really get truly rich emotions that
are things that are meaningful to them,
you know, pictures of themselves,
relationships with their friends.
I mean this is where emotion,
the meat of it is.
Yes. And there was a real, um,
I think responsibility on us to honor the
trust that people have in sharing this
information through us and providing
them the best tools that we can.
And we'll do the genesis of all of this
work is going at the issues that people
are having on the side and understanding
them and understand what's going on,
what happens when there's a breakup and,
and somebody posts pictures
of it after a couple of,
when they were there together.
And have you resolved that
communication between people? Um,
what happens when uh, uh, like a low too,
so that a little bit
bullying is not intentional.
It's somebody coming in and say,
Hey, you look really beautiful today.
And then the person looking at that,
the message feeling bad about their self
image and then navigating that and up
to the point where we began
this partnership setting.
The standard for the industry is like
you look at a report, the report,
Newson criteria,
a hand comes down from the stand,
makes it the piece of content go away.
But who learns from that? How do you grow?
How do you help the community heal
and improve from that? Instead,
what we're trying to
do with, um, with, uh,
the work that we're doing for sample on
bullying is can you talk to the person
if you can feel comfortable doing so
whole uploaded the content? If not,
can you reach out to somebody whom you
trust that can support you navigating
this?
Because the best thing you can do for
somebody who is the recipient or feels
bullied or targeted is to get somebody
in their life can sit down with them and
help them navigate the
situation and hopefully give
them tools to navigate it as
well. And so this is all, this
is the first year of the field,
literally began working on this a year
ago in truly Ernest partnership with our
scientists. But, um,
but I think there's a lot of good work
that remains to be done in the field.
So what do you see in store for the
future of emotion and social media in
Facebook and,
and more generally?
So think we need to be exploring
different ways for people can communicate
emotion to each other.
Um,
there's work around the voice that's
really interesting in terms of sealing
sales work about facial expressions and
how could you actually communicate those
more nuanced feeling sort
of facial expressions.
Is there a better smiley to be had
then the ones that we have today. Um,
and I think there's also a lot of work
to be done in supporting different kinds
of communities we're looking
at, at, at what we can do,
for example, with veterans.
Uh, we're as a community that in
order for them to get support,
it has to come from
somebody who they trust and,
and have a sense of
identification with them.
And so being able to give people
the tools that make them feel seen,
heard, and met on language or spoke to
each other, it seems like it's, it's,
it's something that we're just beginning
to understand that of the work from the
last year and that we will be exploring
for the foreseeable future. Sure.
So what kind of advice do you have for
students or people who are interested in
learning more about emotion, you
know, and how it sort of, um,
I don't know,
sort of manifests in this world,
this social media world and in Facebook.
What would you tell them if they
want to learn more about it?
Two things. One is we do have
this compassion research videos,
articles written, happy to see what
people have to see for themselves there.
And so we're going to be live
streaming the day tomorrow. Um, and uh,
and there should be, there's going to
be lots of really wonderful stuff there.
But the other one is I think the biggest
lesson that I've gotten out of my work
in this space, which is that, um,
a lot of people seem to think that
because it's online it is different and,
and as you start from the thesis,
it has to be different online.
The mechanisms to resolve
just these things.
It has to be different online and they
start carve out areas and it turns out
the listen,
like people are people and if you
want to make a big difference on line,
the best thing that you could possibly
do is do a great job of understanding how
people relate and communicate and resolve
issues with each other in different
kinds of communities across the world.
Turns into debt. You can't, you, you,
you have to be in communal living and
have to see the person that they have to.
So you don't have the luxury of like
being really mean to them and then or
disrespectful to them because
no matter whatever happened,
I mean you're going to have to live with
them the next thing for the cost per
serving. But it had like
people, it has more respectful,
something's funny have to be,
um,
but you could go into a high school
and study what are the emotions that,
uh, like, uh,
teens communicates to each other that
helped them resolve and navigate conflicts
and take those lessons and then go
look at a chapter on one line and say,
what can they, what happened from what
I learned in the high school? What,
how could I apply this to a chat room?
Um,
what I have learned from the wisdom of
a community that seems to be functioning
really well. How can I apply
that in this other context?
And that's the way the
information needs to flow.
So I think the best thing that comes to a,
or a student that's getting started on
the field is to pick a problem that that
gets addressed by successful
communication of emotion in real life,
like within their circle of friends
from in a school or something like that.
And study that and then see how those
results and lessons map to an online
environment because there's a lot of
that that needs to be happening in the
coming years. And again, as I
said, we're just getting started.
Fantastic. Well, thank you so much
for speaking with us today, Arturo.
It was fantastic to hear your thoughts
and thank you very much for having timing.
Thank you.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Facebook engineering
director, our Touro. They
had, thank you so much again.